Billy eilish and Jesse Rutherford seem
to think those comments about their
11-year age Gap are getting kind of old
guys dude here's the thing bro yeah the
rumored couple who first sparked dating
rumors last month seemingly had a little
fun on Halloween poking fun at their age
difference with their Halloween costumes
we're all just doing our thing you know
what I'm saying 20 year old Billy
dressed as a baby while the 31 year old
neighborhood singer sported an old man
costume is it their way of subtly
clapping back at the haters maybe baby
stop what the hell are you talking about
[Music]
the Paris Halloween outing marks the
first time Billy's posted Jesse on the
ground really really cool and while some
fans are fixated on their age Gap these
two seems
foreign
they were first seen out earlier this
month kicking off Halloween festivities
at Universal Studios Horror Nights This
is what I want and days later they were
spotted getting cozy enjoying dinner in
Los Angeles and eyewitness shared
details with E.T about their Night Out
revealing they died for three hours
quote they seem comfortable and happy
together they didn't get up at all from
their table during the meal and were
focused on each other and looking in
each other's eyes the whole time the
eyewitness also shared Jesse kissed her
on the cheek and they both kissed on the
lips if it's something you you feel just
like do that like and I don't know that
sounds like super basic but it literally
is but the sightings and kissing don't
stop there
[Music]
you lose
[Music]
Billy and Jesse were spotted arm and arm
smooching outside a restaurant after
another La date night a week later
[Music]
and with their Halloween outing looks
like Billy's getting more comfortable
giving fans a peek into her love life
the famously private star has been known
to keep details of her romances on the
down low I don't even know before Jesse
Billy was most recently linked to actor
Matthew Tyler Voris whom she started
dating back in April 2021 but they call
things off a year later Matthew
confirmed the split on Instagram while
also shutting down cheating rumors
never let everything good
always
so whether Jesse and Billy are more
trick or more treat we hope the Grammy
winner gets everything she wanted
[Music]
me